what up space fam golson here from anime
opera and i'm back at it again with a
new demon slayer video the topic of this
video will be zenith whether or not he
has already proven himself to be hoshura
level aka as strong as a hashira through
his exploits we're going to be covering
his battle against an upper moon his
face off against muzon and much more so
make sure to stay tuned for this one if
you do enjoy seeing these demonstrator
videos on the channel and want to keep
them coming you know what to do channel
the slayer within and smash that like
button with no mercy remember smashing
that like button is demonstrated energy
and passing a scared moose on energy so
choose wisely if you haven't make this
the video subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
demonstrator videos and updates and
while you wait for the next demonstrator
video to drop feel free to check out my
huge and growing demonstrator playlist
that includes videos in all the hashira
all demon moons why everyone's afraid of
tanjiro and much more link to that is in
the description and now without further
ado let's jump into it spoilers and all
so we won't go over every zion to fight
in detail because there is not much to
say for the earlier ones he pretty much
faints enters his unconscious
avatar-like state and wrecks the earlier
opponents like the tongue demon and the
spider brother demon it is no worthy to
mention that demons like the spider
brother demon do underestimate zenitsu
because he only knows one technique this
could have been a big issue for zainto
after all who would expect a guy who
can't even master the other five thunder
breathing forms to ever be able to
become a hashira however his sensei
encouraged him he said and i quote you
managed to learn one and that's
something it's more than i expected from
you and god i love how zaritsu was such
an underdog his sensei didn't even
expect him to master one but i digress
thunder gramps continues and i quote the
thing is if you can only do one thing
then do it superbly polish it to the
utmost of the utmost end quote he wanted
zaitsu to be rid of all his impurities
so he put him through tough training and
told him to become a blade that's
stronger than anyone i absolutely love
how his sensei aka gramps went from
thinking he couldn't even master one
form to believing he could be the best
and let's see if his prediction comes
true the point here is someone isn't
automatically better just because they
know all the forms of a breath style
after all murata could know all the
water forms but he'd still lose in a
fight against anitsu saitsu shows what
happens if you go deep rather than broad
with your training he's the embodiment
of the bruce lee quote i fear not the
man who has practiced ten thousand kicks
once but i fear the man who has
practiced one kick ten thousand times
and in that sense zeitu is worthy of
being feared perhaps more so than anyone
else despite the poison in his system
his practice paid off and allowed him to
finish the spider brother demon he
finished him off using thunder breathing
first form six-fold which allowed him to
use the first form six times in one
uninterrupted combo attack in that way
this one attack since it's magnified six
times is almost like using six forms
except other thunder style users
probably couldn't move as fast and link
up their attacks as quickly as zenitsu
could this is the story's way of telling
us that zaitsu already compensated for
his lack of forms by honing this one and
zeitsu just continues to be more and
more impressive as the story goes on
zenetsu was really cool in the earlier
fights but his opponents weren't that
strong comparatively speaking his first
pretty strong opponent is daki the
weaker part of upper moon 6. he's not
strong enough yet to beat her on his own
so he double teams her with inosuke
throughout most of the fight at first
they needed tandra's help to get her
head but later they do it without him
and this time sanitsu is the star rather
than inosuke near the end of the fight
zaitsu suddenly pops out of the rubble
doki thinks that i quote i know what
you've got i've seen all your techniques
i know how fast they are end quote but
then saitsu pulls out yet another
improvement while still using the first
form he uses thunderbreeding first form
thunderclap and flash godspeed whenever
you have the word god used in anime it's
hype and a big deal think about god
level threats from one punch man and
zenitsu's attack does not disappoint as
the name suggests he significantly
increased his speed daki who thought she
knew what to expect can't help but think
zainsu is so fast as she's quickly being
dragged along with the attack zanitsu
almost succeeds in cutting her himself
with this attack but her sash-like neck
is just too flexible and bendy if her
neck didn't have that attribute it would
have already been over there is a catch
at this point that zaitsu can only use
godspeed once and then his legs are shot
so he gets one go at it but that really
just makes the attack all the more hype
luckily inosuke appears and helps
zenitsu finish donkey off before his
legs become unusable and the
thunderbreather becomes helpless so at
this point together they succeeded in
beating a part of an upper moon which
even if it's the weaker part is still
pretty cool the next big fight for zany
2 comes a whole 50 chapters later which
is like a quarter of the entire story
but oh man is this fight ever worth the
wait it is zanitsu's best fight he's
never been stronger at least up to this
point and he's definitely never been
cooler in this fight he takes on his old
thunder breathing senpai who has now
become upper moon 6 kaigaku since their
sensei planned for zanitsu and kaigaku
to share the thunder hashira role
kaigaku got furious since he thought he
was so much better than zenitsu and gave
in to the dark side when the opportunity
presented itself it's just the perfect
setup for a battle by himself zaitsu is
fighting a demon-enhanced thunder
breather who also happens to be an upper
moon and who also happens to be his
former senpai whose descent into the
dark side caused their sensei to take
his own life thus revenge is on the line
as well because zainzu loved his sensei
like he was his biological grandpa even
calling him gramps as mentioned another
notable part about this fight is that
zenitsu doesn't show any signs of fear
and he's conscious throughout the fight
it really shows how far he's come from
the crying always passing out zaditu of
the past the trash talk between the two
is great as well kaigaku says zenitsu is
still a shabby little weak runt he asks
him if he can use anything besides the
first form he tries to reestablish
dynamic that they had when kagaku was
stronger than him but zeitsu is not
having it he insults him back saying and
i quote you seem thrilled to have
reached the very bottom of the upper
ranks through merely filling in blank
positions end quote in other words he's
saying kaigaku isn't really strong
enough to be an upper moon but got
thrown in there to fill up the position
and there is some truth to that probably
but that aside he is an official upper
moon and zanitsu is about to take him on
by himself before this only muichiro the
missed hashira took out an upper moon by
himself upper moon 5 to be specific and
muichiro is not only a hashira but
tangen singled him out as one of the
most talented ones along with gyome and
rengoku kagaku seems amused at the fact
that zenitsu can talk back now showing
he's grown as a character and is not the
same crybaby and pushover he was when
they trained together zainsu asks why
would someone poised to acquire thunder
breathing become a demon he's furious
screaming his grandpa killed himself
because kagaku became a demon he passed
on alone by himself with no second
person to make the process quicker and
less painful we get a flashback of
when's any to receive the letter and it
was as expected during the hashida
training arc when he all of a sudden
gets serious and stops acting like his
old self to tanjuro's and our surprise
zanitsu is crying and furious about the
fact that their sensei purposely made
himself suffer so much agony because the
wielders of thunder breathing had
produced a demon at this point the
revenge aspect of this fight is set up
pretty perfectly kaigaku reveals that he
became a demon because he felt that no
matter how hard he worked their sensei
didn't see his value he wouldn't make
him his thunder hashira successor he was
even more upset when their sensei
suggested that kaigaku be a joint
successor with xanitzu you gotta hate
this dude who turned to the dark side
and completely abandoned his sensei who
cared about him so much just because he
didn't want to be a joint thunder
hashira seizu calls pretty much himself
and kaigaku trash and he feels sorry
that his sensei who he endearingly
called gramps had such pathetic
successors he points out the fact that
he could only learn the first form while
kaigaku could learn the rest but not the
first one which is the foundation and
arguably the most important again just
as when his sensei did it kagaku is
furious at being lumped together with
zenitsu thinking he's so superior the
fight starts and obviously i'm rooting
for my boy zenitsu but i gotta point out
that the demon enhanced thunderbreathing
looks very cool it produces actual black
lightning something that i thought was
really cool since i saw it in naruto so
many years ago the coolness of black
lightning aside though now you might
think well they were sort of tied
according to their sensei and perhaps
kaigaku was even a bit in the lead back
in the day so with his demon
enhancements kaigaku should wreck
zenitsu but that's what makes this fight
so great and inspirational despite
giving in to the dark sides we could
improve his speed power and versatility
he still doesn't dominate the fight keep
in mind also demon slayers don't
actually produce their elements in
reality but demon enhanced breath style
users like higaku can actually do it
through their blood demon art so again
saints was actually fighting literal
black lightning that electrifies and
burns as we'll get into still when
kaigaku goes to attack 72 dodges and
even calls kaigaku too slow it's so
awesome seeing these arrogant zenit2
moments because they contrast his usual
character so much and keep in mind
thunderbreathers are already super fast
and kaigaku gained further speed through
becoming a demon and yet our boy is
still calling him too slow after he
actually calls him slow it's revealed
that not only was he fast enough to
dodge kagaku's attack he even delivered
a cut to the upper moon without the
demon noticing i love these moments
where a move is so fast it takes a while
to take effect we then get a flashback
of kokushibo telling kaigaku that it
doesn't matter what he does what's
important is that he lives on so that
there's the possibility that he could
win someday nothing is shameful
according to him including becoming a
demon he asks if kaigaku wants to become
a demon for greater strength and kagaku
agrees he takes a great deal of muslin's
blood and important detail since that's
what's required to turn someone who can
use breathing techniques into a demon
and as we know more muzon blood usually
equals stronger demon kagaku thinks that
compared to the fear kokushibu instilled
in him zaitsu is nothing but the mangaka
does interestingly enough choose to
illustrate zaritsu in a cool way with
whited out eyes this usually happens
with yorichi and tanjiro when a demon is
intimidated by them so the fact that
zenitsu has become a character that
similarly intimidates demons like the
other two is very notable despite
clearly being intimidated by zenitsu
kaigaku tries to calm himself by saying
saints was worthless always sobbing
without any dignity or perseverance
again he's enraged at the thought that
to quote him the rotten old man said
zainson kagaku would be successors
together he is so averse to thinking of
zainto as being his equal so the fact
that non-demon zenytu seems to be
beating and taunting him so far must
really irritate him kagaku is far from
finished though and he launches another
attack which is composed of five
successive attacks in one breath and in
the blink of an eye this actually does
cut zaitsu's cheeks and zenitsu can tell
that kaigaku has already eaten so many
people to gain this much power the
attacks continue higaku is using every
other thunder breathing form except the
first one and combining it with his
black lightning blood demon art zainsoo
notices that kaigaku sword doesn't need
to connect kagaku can launch waveform
attacks in the form of black lightning
that can hurt his target i hate kaigaku
but again i have to admit it's very cool
to be able to actually summon your
element like this in battle after a
while kaigaku asks zenitsu and i quote
how's the sharpness of my blade infused
with blood demon art an attack that
slashes and burns the flesh end quote he
continues to land attacks on zenitsu our
boy is all cut up we're further told
that any slashing attacks that kaigaku's
victims take will continue to rend ak
tear apart their flesh his power burns
into the eyes and body he says he became
a demon and surpassed thunder breathing
he thinks he's one now as a very injured
zaitsu is seemingly free falling to his
end kaigaku insists that he's special
he's different from zenitsu he's not
like zenitsu at all saints who recalls
back in the day when his gramps told him
to learn from kagaku's example again
reminding us of how kaigaku actually
used to be ahead of and stronger than
zenitsu even before he turned into an
upper moon saints recalls how he used to
look up to kaigaku and how kaigaku was
special to him in gramps he has to come
to terms with finishing off a dude who
he once thought of as a brother and he
finally does apologizing to his gramps
and saying that his and kagaku's paths
diverged because of this section here i
feel like zaitsu could have actually
finished the battle off sooner if he was
as ruthless as kaigaku but he probably
needed some time to build up enough
conviction to finally finish off his old
senpai keep in mind before tundra and
the others zanitsu pretty much just had
his gramps and kaigaku and now that his
gramps is gone kaigaku is the last tie
to that simpler time when his gramps and
senpai were the only special people in
his life but as i mentioned zaitsu makes
up his mind here and prepares his final
attack his face is tearing apart from
kagaku's attacks that continue to tear
apart the body like poison or even worse
than poison long after the initial
attack was received zainsu apologizes to
kaigaku and then unleashes the seventh
form of thunder breathing thunder
breathing honoy kazuchi nokami aka
thunder breathing flaming thunder god
this is by far the coolest thunder
breathing form we've seen yet and cooler
still zanitsu created it yes the dude
who couldn't even learn the five other
forms turned out to be skilled enough to
create a brand new one as with his
godspeed move it contains the word god
in it again to connote how powerful it
is and it even takes the form of a
lightning dragon often considered the
strongest mythical beast in the animal
kingdom i went into how breath styles
that take the forms of dragons in the
demon slayer story like sun breathing
water breathing flame breathing and
thunder breathing are especially strong
in my 16 breath styles ranked from weak
as the strongest video and that's why i
think it's all the more significant here
that zenith's attack looks like a
lightning dragon in demon slayer the
original and strongest breath aka the
breath of the sun has a move called
dragon sun halo head dance that
similarly takes the form of a dragon so
combine the fact that a dragon is
associated with the strongest breath
style with the fact that dragons are
considered to be the strongest creatures
so strong they don't even exist and yeah
you can see that the mangaka is pointing
to this being a very powerful move it's
not a stretch to say this must be the
strongest thunder breathing form ever
created and it came from our very own
crybaby underdog zenitsu the move cuts
off kaigaku's demon head and as further
praise for the technique kagaku thinks
to himself that he didn't even see it
because it was so fast take that in it
was so fast that a thunder breathing
upper moon couldn't even see it and it
was powerful enough to take his head in
one go as well as he's about to pass on
kaigaku is furious thinking the old man
taught zenitsu something that he never
taught him he thought their sensei was
playing favorites after all however
zaisu says no he wasn't that kind of
person saints reveals that this was in
fact his own form he created it so he
could fight as an equal with kaigaku
ironically despite how much kaigaku
hated the implication that he and zeitsu
were equal in power because he thought
he was so much superior saints was the
one who actually shows his superiority
in this fight not just that he proved
that he was superior without needing to
get a demon upgrade now although i
always like hyping up zenitsu it must be
noted that zaintsu passed out after
beating kaigaku he's falling to his
death and kaigaku is glad to see it he
thinks eliza ainson didn't beat him at
least it will be a tie but yushiro comes
and saves zanitsu while also rubbing it
in kaigaku's upper moon face he tells
kaigaku someone who never gives to
others will someday become unable to
receive anything from them only wanting
is in the end the same as having nothing
after his words he lets kaigaku know
it's a pity to die alone and then peaces
out with zenitsu who did win and was
saved because he was nice to others gave
to others and thus had friends unlike
kaigaku zaitsu has a brief moment as
he's passed out where he sees his gramps
on the other side of a river the one
probably separating the living from the
dead he apologizes to his grams for
everything saying he wanted to become a
hashira when his gramps was still alive
but his gramps isn't angry at all at
zenitsu he just cries tears of joy and
says he's proud of him i mean i'm almost
tearing up reading this section but
let's just take a second to realize that
making a former hashira proud is not an
easy task and it's a great moment for
zainsu's character where he pretty much
lived up or even surpassed the sensei's
high expectations of him as he's
treating zanitsu you sure goes on to say
that kagaku slashes on zaitsu's face
will open up all the way to zainto's
eyes if not treated he has to use an
agent that stops the advance of blood
demon art developed by tamayo to save
zanitsu he goes on to say to zainto that
kaigaku still hadn't mastered his
techniques and abilities which is lucky
if the fight had been one year later
kaigaku probably would have killed him
immediately whether this is true or not
zhang's performance against an upper
moon was very impressive here but if you
look at the fact that zeitsu could have
died if he wasn't saved by yushiro and
you look at yushiro's words about
kaigaku being able to crush him one year
later then it makes zaitsu look somewhat
less strong however i will note that as
mentioned it does seem like zains was
holding back his finishing move until he
made peace with ending kagaku's demon
life which if that's the case means he
probably could have finished him off
sooner before taking on so much more
damage damage that only grew worse as
each wound continued to spread over the
whole body during the course of the
battle furthermore yoshida said probably
not certainly suggesting he's not even
positive and in our boy's defense he's
been progressing super fast and chances
are he'd be much stronger in a year as
well kaigaku wouldn't be the only one
growing in power so yeah zaitsu was
already impressive becoming the second
person to solo an upper moon and
arguably he could have finished him off
even sooner if he wasn't struggling with
the whole facing his senpai slash
brother thing now the conditions for
becoming a hashida are as follows
according to the kyoto rengoku side
story part 1 one is to be at least a
kino aka the highest of the ten ranks in
the core and exterminate over 50 demons
or to defeat one of the 12 demon moons
meaning it could even be a lower moon
since zenitsu soloed an upper moon here
he should definitely qualify for a
promotion to hashira at this point in
the story and that's even if there
weren't a shortage in the number of
hashira they already had but since there
is a huge shortage at the end of the
story if the team failed to defeat muzon
and the slayer core had to go on
existing zaitsu would most definitely be
promoted in name as well because he more
than met the criteria thus at this point
it's not debatable we can already refer
to zaitsu as a hashira in spirit and
qualification and i love the fact that
he got to see his grandpa spirit after
he succeeded in reaching this level
since he always wanted his gramps to see
him become a hashida now even if he did
nothing else in the story he already
proved himself to be hostile level
however he does go on to do even more in
fact our boy even faces muzon albeit
along with a bunch of other demon
slayers yes he gets taken out by muzon
for a while and multiple times but as
usual our thunderboy gets back up
eventually in fact muzon can hardly
believe how many times he keeps getting
back up it's amazing that the dude who
started out as a crybaby scared enough
of weak demons to feign on the spot has
become a guy who will consciously keep
getting up again and again to face the
strongest demon he uses godspeed against
muzon and even seventh form flaming
thunder god and the attack noticeably
hurts muzon however zenitu suggests that
the cut was too shallow and only a
bright red blade can do enough damage so
yeah zenitsu is not as much of a star in
this fight as tanjira which makes sense
since tangero is the protagonist but
like everyone else he plays his
invaluable role and even after he thinks
his legs are shot and he won't be able
to move he channels his gramps's memory
his eyes go all white and we see him
again launch another thunderclap and
flash he continues to be hard on himself
though ironically calling himself too
slow and usually he would have been out
of commission ages ago but he keeps
going showing how much stronger he's
become he unleashes god speed
thunderclap and flash again dragging
muzon along with his strong fast move
that cuts through the ground itself then
tanjiro continues where zainzu left off
and thanks to zainto's help succeeds in
pinning muzon to the wall this pinning
becomes the definitive moment that leads
to muzon's defeat so it's cool that
zeitsu is largely to thank for tundra
being able to pull it off muzon remains
pinned as the sun comes out he then
turns into a giant demon baby and
despite his attempt to escape the sun
ends up finishing him off notably the
hashira play a big role in making sure
big giant baby muzon doesn't escape
muzon is defeated a bunch of hashtag
pass on and you think the threat is over
but then it's revealed that muzon turned
tundra into the next more powerful demon
king after multiple uses of godspeed and
other attacks including flaming thunder
god along with taking repeated damage
from muzon himself zainsu is still alive
to help deal with this demon king tundra
threat admittedly he's not in fighting
shape but he's up and even goes to hug
tanjuro trying to get him to remember
who he is and to not attack nezuko he's
sent flying back by one of tundra's
attacks however he's still not done and
continues to scream for nezuko and he
continues to beg tundra to stop this
madness thanks to kano who delivers the
medicine they succeed in turning tundra
back into a human and after the demon
fighting is finally over zanitsu is okay
promising nezuko that he'll make tundra
pay his whole life for what he did to
him and to his wife nezuko it's
impressive to see that zenitsu can walk
after some rest and even has enough
energy to get jealous when sun emi pats
nezuko on the head unlike tundra who
loses the use of one eye and arm zenitsu
could potentially from what we've seen
go on to be stronger than ever he hasn't
been nerfed at all from what we can tell
and if there was a need he would
definitely go on to become a hashida and
not just any hashira but the thunder god
hashida i say this because the word god
has only been associated so much with
zenith's thunder attacks and with no
other thunder breather and you can argue
that he surpassed the rest too by
creating the strongest thunder breathing
form yet that takes the form of a dragon
and is fast enough that even a
demon-enhanced talented thunder breather
can't see it let alone react in time to
avoid it now it should be said in the
extended ending while tundra was forcing
them to visit all the graves of the
fallen for three days zainsu started
crying about his painful legs and nezuko
carried him on her shoulders but i
believe this would have eventually
passed just as it did after he uses
godspeed against daki so yeah zaitsu is
arguably the strongest of our trio after
tundra got nerfed but more importantly
for him he gets to fulfill his dream of
marrying nezuko which i'm sure means way
more to him than any amount of power
ever could and they even have kids
together i gotta say it's a perfect
ending for our boy zanitsu and i also
have to say iguro is probably my
favorite hashira akaza is my favorite
demon but zaritsu is my favorite main
character we won't count yorichi since
he's long gone by the beginning of the
series but zaitsu is just amazing and
his journey from crybaby to thunder god
hero facing down the demon king is
inspirational beyond words and that is
it for zenitsu who in fact not only
deserved to be a hashira but is arguably
the strongest thunder hashira in history
and used his own created form to solo an
upper moon who claimed he surpassed
thunder breathing itself keep in mind
zainsu didn't even awaken his demon
slayer mark probably because the mangaka
didn't want us to worry about zainson
not living past 25 years old like the
other marked ones but if he did awaken
his demonstrator mark obtained the
bright red blade and got all the other
power-ups he may well have surpassed
every surviving character after the
defeat of muzon and remember tundra has
been nerfed so it wasn't necessary but
if it had been zaintu really might have
been capable of becoming the strongest
as his gramps told him to and if we look
at it in the sense that his gramps was
telling him to become the strongest user
of thunder breathing then he did in fact
succeed and yes to some i may be over
hyping zanitsu but i'd rather overhype
him than underhype him especially
considering the fact that he started out
as a crybaby and the biggest underdog in
the series to the point where sensei
didn't even expect him to pull off one
form at first even munata learned more
water breathing forms than that if you
did enjoy this video and want to keep
them coming channel the thunder god
hoshida within and smash that like
button with no mercy remember smashing
that like button is bosses that needs to
energy and passing is scared moves on
energy so choose wisely if you haven't
make this the video you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
you guessed it all notifications or you
will miss future demonstrator videos and
updates and while you wait for the next
demonstrator video to drop feel free to
check out my huge and growing
demonstrator playlist that includes
videos of all the hashita all demon
moons why everyone is afraid of tanjiro
and much more link to that is in the
description leave suggestions for video
topics you are burning up to see that
you couldn't find in the playlist and
until next time see ya space cowboys